well we've had a big victory recently uh
a number of major car companies that
announced that they're pulling AM radio
from new cars and and that is an
enormous problem that is a really bad
decision uh if you look Nationwide there
they're roughly 4 500 AM radio stations
all across the country about 82 million
Americans listen to AM radio every month
and and pulling AM radio from cars does
enormous damage and and so I joined
together with Ed Markey Ed Markey is a
liberal Democrat senator from
Massachusetts Ed may be the most liberal
senator in the entire U.S Senate I'm the
most conservative senator in the U.S
Senate it is rare that Ed Markey and I
are together on a bill but we joined
together on a bill to require that car
companies continue to provide AM radio
in the new cars they're selling and and
that's important for a lot of reasons
it's important as a matter of public
safety if you look during emergencies
whether it's hurricanes or tornadoes or
floods
AM radio is the most reliable means of
communicating with people often when you
have a disaster power lines go out power
goes down FM radio goes down it takes
higher power and AM radio is the means
of communication of the last resort that
that
Americans in distress rely upon to get
life-saving information
but beyond that
AM radio in particular is an oasis of
talk radio we have seen conservative
talk radio stall watch Rise Up from Rush
Limbaugh to Sean Hannity to Mark Levin
and and and millions of Americans listen
to talk radio frankly I think that's one
of the reasons why the car makers were
eager to pull AM radio out of their cars
is that I think part of this is an
effort to silence voices with which they
disagree and and I gotta say we
introduced our legislation and within
four days Ford Motor Company one of the
biggest car companies in the world
reversed course and announced it was
going to include AM radio in all of its
vehicles and so that was a big victory
to begin with but we're going to keep
pressing until we pass this legislation
because consumers
ought to have Choice ought to have the
ability to choose to listen to AM radio
if that's what they want to do but the
argument the car makers made this
initially started with just electric
vehicles and they argued that AM radio
interfered uh there was interference
between AM radio and and the electric
wiring well it turns out that there's a
fairly simple fix in terms of shielding
that wiring that's not terribly
expensive that enables AM radio to work
just fine with electric vehicles when it
when this was limited to a handful of
electric vehicles it was not that
significant a problem now number one
we're getting more and more electric
vehicles on the road so that's becoming
a broader problem but number two car
makers were not just limiting this to
electric vehicles they were pulling am
radios off of their internal combustion
engine Vehicles their gasoline-powered
Vehicles as well and so it was becoming
an inter industry move that was within a
few years
millions of consumers would would have
cars that couldn't get AM radio and and
that I believe was an enormous problem
and so what this bill does is it
requires that car makers provide am
radios and and let customers decide let
the consumers decide you know they're
Texans all across the state they're
farmers and ranchers who in rural
communities rely on AM radio sometimes
it's the only radio you can get uh they
rely on it for for crop reports and
weather reports they rely on it when
they're out out in the tractor that's
what they're listening to and and and
there are also communities smaller
communities you know one of the great
things about AM radio
is it has a very low barrier entry so
that if someone wants to go up and put
up a radio show it is relatively
inexpensive it is much less expensive
than an FM show which takes much higher
uh an FM station takes a lot more power
a lot a lot more equipment it's a lot
more expensive what that means is is
with AM radio you have many more voices
and and in particular you have voices uh
in individual communities so you have
stations that focus on issues in the
African-American Community you have
Hispanic Community you have stations
that focus on issues impacting Asian
American communities that diversity of
views is is good for the country
House Republicans in the house as a
whole uh voted to pass the deal that was
not terribly surprising you saw a whole
bunch of Democrats support it and you
saw some Republicans support it uh I
think at the end of the day the White
House got a lot more out of this deal
than Republicans did this deal gives
four trillion dollars in new death
that's a massive amount of new debt and
it does so in exchange for very modest
spending risk reductions spending
reductions that I think are too small to
make a material difference fixing the
problem we have look some basic numbers
2017 five years ago in 2017 the entire
federal budget was about four trillion
dollars
federal tax revenues were about 3.3
trillion dollars now that means doing
quick math
that the deficit that year was about 700
billion dollars
what happened from 2017 to today well
the federal budget exploded covid was
the excuse and then you had a democrat
congress and Democrat president that
went on a multi-trillion dollar spending
spree and so now five years later the
federal budget has gone from four
trillion dollars to 6.6 trillion dollars
that is a massive increase
um
federal tax revenues even though we
passed the big tax cut in 2017 remember
Democrats said tax revenue would plummet
turns out they were wrong what they told
the American people was flat out false
federal tax revenues went from 3.3
trillion to just under 5 trillion so
federal tax revenues went through the
roof because the tax cuts produced
economic growth but the problem is
spending
is now much much higher if we had
limited spending we'd have a surplus
right now but the Democrats didn't want
to limit spending and what happened to
the national debt in 2017 the national
debt was 20 trillion dollars now it is
32 trillion dollars and with this deal
it is going to be 36 trillion dollars
that is nearly doubling the debt uh in
in in just a few years that is
profoundly Reckless if you're pissed off
at the inflation you're paying right now
when you go to the grocery store when
you go to the gas pump when you pay your
bills at the end of the month the reason
is the Democrats are printing money and
borrowing money they don't have and and
this this deal should have done much
much more to address the underlying
problem this is a big missed opportunity
and unfortunately
as Joe Biden is crowing this was
Republicans agreeing to fund every one
of his left-wing prior authorities I
think that was a big big mistake